good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is scp-965 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures scp-965 is contained within a
framed ready to install window and forth
referred to as scp-965 - one composed of
at least six panes of clear glass or
similar material measuring at least 15
by 30 centimeters scp-965 - one must in
turn be kept within an environmentally
controlled storage facility capable of
withstanding significant seismic
disturbances scp-965 - one should be
inspected at least once per week to
check for degradation of material at all
times at least two similar framed
windows must be present and within
separate chambers in additional padding
and insulation no other windowpane
measuring greater than 14 centimeters
wide or 29 centimeters tall between them
and the current scp-965 - one the
lighting within the chamber containing
scp-965 must be at a minimal of 130
candless at any time personnel are
within set chamber except during
research while scp-965 is currently
contained within scp-965 - one hour
inability to control its movement upon
destruction of scp-965 - one through
means beyond proximity have prompted its
elevation to euclid status research into
a more permanent means to contain
scp-965 is ongoing and individual
experiments may be carried out by
clearance level 1 personnel after
approval by level 3 administration
description
scp-965 is a visual manifestation that
occurs within framed windows this
manifestation takes the shape of a
shadowed face of an apparently pale
skinned male that is looking through the
window the exact details shown vary as
thus the direction of orientation as
well as the age of the person
however sufficient detail shows it to
consistently be the same being at
differing points in its life between the
approximate ages of 10 and 55 research
into an individual matching scp-965 as
thus far proven inconclusive scp-965
will only appear when the relative
lighting on the outside of the window
falls below five candles regardless of
lighting on the inside such terms are
possible because the face will only
appear in a fully assembled window frame
though it does not need to be currently
installed thus far scp-965 has not shown
any ability to intentionally move from
one glass pane to another even within
the same installation it is only able to
attain a new manifestation point upon
the destruction of the current scp-965 -
one at which point its new habitat will
be reclassified as scp-965 - 1 the face
is visible from the outside portion of
scp-965 - 1 but despite its
two-dimensional nature it is described
as looking away into the room initial
effects caused by a CP 965 are reports
of unease nervousness and low-grade
paranoia these sensations will overcome
anyone within visual range of the
manifestation
even if obscured such as by curtains
based upon reports pertaining to
residents of the house where scp-965 was
discovered encountered problems sleeping
experiments were conducted using d-class
personnel who were made to sleep in a
chamber where scp-965 - one was
installed an individual that is sleeping
in any area visible to scp-965 went
manaphy
will invariably have dreams of a
disturbing nature usually involving
being chased attacked tormented etc
though without physical contact within
the dream with repeated incidents
involving the same subject as few as
three never more than ten dream cycles
before onset scp-965 will begin
manifesting with a more explicit smile
than normal after this point the subject
will begin complaining of heartburn or
abdominal pain and often begin to vomit
blood or have blood and bodily wastes
this is caused by the victims suffering
ulcers and low-grade hemorrhaging
throughout varied locations in their
gastrointestinal tract the current
hypothesis as to the cause of these
afflictions is scp-965 s influence
artificially accelerating the body's
reactions to elevated stress and fear
levels subjects who advance to this
stage have also reported continuing
experiences of the facial manifestations
in windows during dreams as well as in
peripheral vision while awake even after
being removed from the vicinity of
scp-965 most suffer from low grade but
lasting feelings of paranoia as well as
sensations that they are being watched
or followed whether this is in fact some
remnant influence left behind or
standard symptoms of the stress followed
by the traumatic intrusion of scp-965
into their psyche is under investigation
scp-965 has produced no noise to date
and there have been no reported
instances of scp-965 animating in any
way once it appears however it is
capable of disappearing and reappearing
at will in different poses scp-965 also
shows signs of sentience it has been
observed to show disappointment if it
manifests to an empty room irritation or
anger when
Festing before someone that had broken a
prior scp-965 - one and one instance of
visible fear when in the presence of
agent who had earlier participated in
its retrieval addendum incident 965 -
[Music]
119th routine testing involving the
destruction of scp-965 - one confirmed
that while a multi paint window may act
as multiple holding zones sufficient
damage to the overall structure
disqualifies it as a possible
replacement
unfortunately scp-965 instead manifested
in an adjacent experimentation chambers
observational window due to the high
standards of foundation equipment this
required the windows complete removal
and destruction via tactical breaching
charge scp-965 was viewed with
significantly hostile expressions for
one month after the incident addendum
incident 965 - 220 doctor requested
transfer away from the project involving
scp-965 she was reported as beginning to
have visions of scp-965 and to
experience feelings of paranoia similar
to those affected during sleep despite
not having slept in the presence of
scp-965 herself doctor temporarily
relieved of duties and assigned his
psychological care no other instances of
scp-965 affecting personnel who have not
slept in its presence have been reported
[Music]
okay that about does it for today thank
you all for listening and you are all
dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette Desmond Hoskins and
Gansu Barry thank you all very much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
know that I am nice selling merch I have
about 12 designs up right now all I've
worked pretty hard on by lugu in several
different styles is one of them but I've
also done logos for the shark punchin
Center a spicy crust pizzeria some
original designs some of which based on
0 4 9 6 8 to have the mobile task force
nine-tailed Fox logo I was a graphic
designer before I started trying to do
this for a living so I have a pretty
good skill set when it comes to making
original designs I don't make very much
from it at all by any means is not
getting rich off of it but if you'd like
to support my channel on a one-time
basis maybe patreon is too much of a
commitment for you get a t-shirt or a
hoodie or a phone kiss or something like
that red bubble is pretty good for that
kind of thing anyway I've shelled enough
for this video thanks very much for
listening
and I'll see you all soon bye bye
[Music]
you